[Music]
hello thank you so much for having me
I'm super super excited to be here this
is one of my absolute favorite
conferences and this is such a massive
and awesome audience so thank you give
yourselves all a round of applause
I love CSS comps because it honestly
feels like this giant family we're all
interviews really nerdy things we're all
into them together and it really just
feels like this big family so I wanted
to announce something that I've been
working on so the past couple of months
almost a year that kind of feels like my
baby and this is the only appropriate
place to announce it I'm writing a book
called the front end developers
guidebook I just had to announce up here
cuz I love all of you so this is about
front-end development everything from
soft skills like how to learn about side
projects and make time to technical
skills all foundations also
internationalisation SEO accessibility
performance all those things so for
doing that for a while I'm working with
a publisher is smashing and it'll be out
soon there's a lot of practical stuff in
this book but in this talk we'll flip
that over and we'll end this conference
with more of a party mode we're going to
write a CSS game but don't worry we'll
go over some something for you to learn
we'll talk about SAS data structures
there's going to be a lot of sass
involved in this
we heard some really good talks about
CSS and JavaScript this is going to be
writing functional programs inside of
sass itself we're going to kind of flip
that script a bit we're going to do some
pixel art we're actually going to create
some generative pixel art based on
things that were writing individually
inside of staff so that will be some fun
we'll do some functions and loops will
talk about grid very briefly we'll learn
about some pointer events CSS animation
and basically how to crash your web
browser because none of these things are
really great for production but they're
great for making games for having fun
for experimenting with CSS so let's meet
our cast have you seen these
people around these are our lovely
organizers and MC is here today and I
wanted to kind of bring them in the game
I wanted to give him high fives for the
awesome job that they did putting this
together I was also inspired by Mario so
I thought maybe I could get the cast of
her game put them into Mario and make
some magic happen so we're going to do
that I brought them into illustrator
first and I mapped out pixel by pixel
exactly what I wanted them to look like
and I translated them to map so we rehab
Paulie Kevin Tim Christina you got
Jessica and once this is all said and
done if all works out well we will have
created this CSS comp high-fives game oh
gosh has been going a little crazy so
last for eight seconds it counts up our
points all of this is done in just CSS I
am going to use gulp to essentially just
run browser sync so that you're not
waiting for me while I'm doing this and
also runs off but yeah let's get started
this all boils down to CSS and HTML so
the first thing we wanted to do is build
those characters but those characters
are going to take a while doing them
pixel by pixel so we'll do a little bit
of a simplified demo with a heart first
thing we want to do is hook this into
the HTML with a clasp we'll call this
class pixelize heart I'm using EMA so I
just hit tab it creates that for me then
I want to open my heart F CSS and get
started next thing that we want to do is
create a map of color so thus they want
to use red and transparent we can map
this with a key and a value so we can
map this with ofer transparent and then
we can use our for red cool so now we
know what colors we're going to
correlate our pixels to the second thing
that we can do is determine the size of
the pixels so let's make this 20s a
little bit easier to see for all you out
there now what we can do is start
creating this pixel art I have a map
called pixel art it's a variable and I'm
going to have multiple maps inside of
that map so I'm going to call this map
heart and that's going to be a map
itself and we're going to create this by
adding multiple lines that are included
in parentheses determine the number of
rows that we have
going to have six rows it's going to
look something like this and they're
going to fill those with the pixels that
we're expecting to have trust me there's
a method to my madness
you can then go through and draw out all
these pixels individually like you would
see in a heart and I know that you can't
see it yet but in a moment I can
highlight all these Reds and show you
what it's going to look like in a moment
so here I am just drawing this out and I
could see that I've aired here so I'm
going to fix that and really you can
just set these colors you can apply
multiple colors you can create like
stripes if I want to if I could add more
colors to the list but when I highlight
the Reds you can see very lightly that
I've created a heart out of OHS and ours
to create this pixel map so we have our
heart pixel map but now we need to read
through this entire map to pull out
those pixels what we're going to be
using here is box shadow because box
shadow is really easy to hack and it
allows us to give an unlimited number of
arguments in the property list itself so
we can have an unlimited number of
arguments and we can place them based on
an x and y coordinates from the top left
as pixel values so let's just make this
let's write that function because we can
write functions in that so inside of
here I'm going to say we first are going
to generate the shadow list so we can
create an empty string to begin with and
we'll fill that as we go and then we're
going to also need to get the road so as
I mentioned earlier the roads is going
to be the length of the matrix since we
have six of these one two three four
five six going down that's going to then
denote the roads for our entire matrix
and we can iterate through those roads
to get the actual row number so in SAS
we can also use a for-loop
at four row from one through the number
of rows here so here I'm going to use
rows and variable that we just set I'm
going to set that row number so it's
just going to be row num and then we can
use the int value to pull that in to the
nth value of the matrix and the row so
now we know what the actual row number
is that we have landed on now we can
filter that again and get the column
number
the column is going to be at 4:00 call
from one through the length of the row
number because that means that we're
going to go through all nine values that
are in that row and get the column value
and finally we can see where the dot is
so from that we can see if the dot is
the end value of the row number in the
column so now we know if we are in an R
or an O value once we have that we can
start building this shadow list of you
have so the shadow list then becomes the
shadow list this is how you append in
SAS plus the values that were pulling
from here so we can get the exposition
by using size the pixel value that we
set us twenty pixels times the column
plus me to have a space here for the
syntax of drop shadow plus the size
times the row and from here we can get
the color so we also want to add another
space we want to then map guess which is
how we access items inside of the map
itself we're going to access from the
colors map and then use the dot value to
pull in either transparent or red now
we're converting that from a no earn are
to transparent or red we're almost done
with this item the shadow list but next
we then have to add a comma we have to
have a comma between every single item
in this list except for the very last
item because if the last item has a
comma it'll invalidate and it won't show
up so we have to do a negated if
statement so let's say at if not how is
equal to the length of row num which
means that we're at the very last item
right number nine and rest the very last
row so we can say Rho is equal to Rose
then we want to add a comma then the
shadow list becomes the shadow list plus
a comma cool so the last thing I want to
do is return a value we have to use at
return unquote because currently it is
still a string that we have unquote the
shadow list and we can finally return a
value so nothing is going to appear
until we actually use it inside of our
div that we created in the page so let's
make this an after pseudo element and
then apply any of the height and of
width first so the height can be the
size and the width
can be the size and we want to give us a
content since it's a after suit helmet
this is going to be very fast ESS so I
apologize about all of the like improper
placement of all these things if you
always make sure they're nice and neat
and orderly and inside the box and we
can use a function on the right hand
side of the property so here we'll use
our function which is called pixel eyes
and we need to map yet because again the
heart map is inside of another map so
we're going to map get pixel art yep
pixel art is our a sort of map of our
map map get pixel art and heart and then
we're going to send the size value again
which is default and it's set globally
here so once I save this our heart will
appear appears in the screen I somehow
didn't mess up that's great
the next thing I'm going to do is step
in set this I'm going to use this
ampersand which acts as an anchor in
sass so what will happen here is I can
edit pixelized Hart give it some
properties and it still has six pies
Hart after setup in there I'm going to
give this an outline so I can debug this
a line 1px solid as you see that this
element is not taking up any space on
the page because we haven't given it a
width or a height and that's not great
if you want to use this within our game
itself it has to take up some space so
first I want to give a special relative
oh and I then want to give it a width
and height and I'm going to be using
that based on the size that we've
dynamically created in this nature
because we can also set the size so I'm
going to give it a height and the height
again is the length that matrix times
the size so get the pixel size and
multiply it by the length of that matrix
and in this case the matrix is map get
pixel art Hart copy that paste it in
there and then height the width is going
to be the length of one of those columns
so since we're out inside that loop
again we can get the size and the length
of just one of those columns so we're
going to have to map get one of them and
use that nth value again to say ends of
this matrix and the first column because
why not so say that and it is now
properly placed but you can see that
it's shifted over and the reason why is
because black shadow starts at the
bottom right corner of the div it starts
at the end of it so now we have to shift
this up so we can say top of negative
size maybe left of negative size and
boom our heart is placed inside of the
div as we expected based on this heart
that we just created out of literally
letters on the screen together here so
we can then take this idea and open
something like I have a character's SCSS
where I already did this and I'm going
to just uncomment and zoom out of here
so you can see what the characters
actually look like my vision is forever
ruined but it's fine
so if I
save this and then I open I have a
characters file you can see all the
characters have appeared out of this
generated map and you can dynamically
change the colors so like if I wanted to
go into here and I wanted to change all
of the black to like a red because why
not once I save this instantly it'll all
change so you can just create this art
dynamically in your browser and it's
really fun to play with you can also
animate this if you're a masochist
and want to make your browser run really
slowly it wouldn't recommend animating
box-shadow
but it is an option so the next thing we
want to do is keep some score we have
our characters but we don't really have
our game set so we have to create like
our entire game area in here we're going
to use Emmet to make this really quick
for ourselves I'm going to have a list
so just UL and that list is going to
have a class of game area and then
within that I want to have a couple of
list items so I can say that I want to
have a list item next to that I want to
have an input it's going to be a
checkbox so it's going to type equals
checkbox this is going to be our click
area that we're going to use to sort of
make sure that we've counted up these
points from once we click we'll count up
the points
next to that we have a div and it's
going to be a character and with Emmet
you can just do times three hit tab and
now I have this list and within it I
have these three list items inside the
list item I have an input and I have our
character nothing is going to show up
until I go through and make sure that I
add a little character so here I can say
pixel eyes maybe we'll have a Kevin in
there we can have three Kevin's or I can
mix this up and add like let's add poly
here let's add a Christina on our screen
and now all of our characters are happy
and have appeared and they're ready for
high fives also with these boxes you can
add a border radius make them round you
can make them bigger or smaller based on
the pixel size it's four pixels here but
it really allows for a variety of
options that you can play around with so
we also want to add a place for our
score to show up here so we can just
have an h2 with a score and then inside
of that lets get a span with a class of
score that will access
later to show our points go zoom out
there a little you know with this screen
here alright so the next thing we want
to do is then open a new CSS file just
to keep it organized we're going to open
our game play s CSS so game plays it's
called
I've opened this now we need to design
this click area so that's not just a
small check box over there so we can
just quickly edit this maybe give it a
position of absolute so that it shows
within its parent there we can give it a
display:block and then we can do some
things like give it an outline so we can
debug this this is my favorite way to
debug because outline doesn't take any
space on the page whereas border does so
I have that outlined maybe I want to
give it a width of 40 pixels and a
height of 40 pixels so you can see it
it's currently behind the characters I
believe so we need to give it a Z index
the index of three could work at this
point I'd probably want to create a Z
index map and then use that to adjust
accordingly so that everything is
orderly but like I said we're just going
to speed right this game and then here I
can do appearance none to get rid of
that checkbox this works really well in
WebKit and in Chrome does not work in
Firefox so you would have to create a
span that surrounds your check box style
that span and have appearance none on
your check not a parent son you have to
have a display of nominative checkbox in
order to make this work in Firefox so
everything else will be identical except
for this little quick area I also want
to give us a top of like negative 10
pixels and a left of like negative 5 so
that it just positions nicely maybe you
want to give it a tap of 10 so once I've
done that when I click on it now you
can't tell that it clicked on it so we
need to make sure that there's some kind
of feedback mechanism I don't even know
that I can hover over it because the
cursor hasn't changed so a really nice
cursor for this is called grab because
it's like a little hand you I don't know
if you could see you here basic a little
hand hovering here that's a little hand
for the high-five so that was good we
now know that we're hovering and maybe
we want to add a property of if it's
checked given like a background of green
or something so we know we clicked on it
ok cool so we know now what's things
what's not we can get rid of this we'll
deal with that later we can get rid of
this outline great let's count up some
points so here we currently have score
and we have a span next to it with a
class of score that has nothing in it
because we haven't provided any value
but we can do this with a property
called counter increment in CSS counter
increment was originally intended for
outlines when you have an unlimited
amount of data that you're counting up
and you want to be able to just
increment it up we can use counter
increments in our game to check where we
have our check boxes and apply the value
put it out on the game so inside of
score we can give it an after clear
element with content and the content
that we're spending over that we're
pulling some Dom sending over is going
to be the counter of a game so once I
save this zero will appear because we
don't have any points yet on the game
and we can mitigate that by adding the
rest of the things that matter so the
game area needs a counter reset of game
we're naming it here and then after that
we want to give the Kliq area when it is
checked a counter increment of game when
I say that now once I've clicked on
these you'll see that it's starting to
count up our score so counter increment
can be used for that if you want to make
this game even challenging we can also
use a decrement catta increment is won
by nature but you can customize it so
you can add multiple points negative
points and really play this up we want
to make it challenging so we do want to
make it more challenging not in that way
but we want to add a shield because
right now I can just click on all of
these and count up and I win so let's go
back into our index let's you know get
rid of some of this stuff I'm going to
say that to my clipboard because we want
to add a shield inside of our list we
still have this unordered list with a
class of game area inside of that we
still have our list item but instead of
having it directly next to the input and
click area of the character we want to
wrap that inside of a character wrapper
so let's say we're going to say dot care
sir wrapper and then next to that we
want to have a shield so we're going to
have a shield plus a character wrapper
and maybe we want to have nine of those
so once I hit tab now I have my list
item with the shield a character wrapper
inside of the character wrapper we have
our checkbox aka our click area we have
our characters and we're ready to go and
make this game what it is we also have 9
of them so we can make kind of a grid a
3x3 grid and here I can go through and
add pixelized characters let's have all
of the Tim's just lines right up know
about all the other characters here
let's add a Jessica let's add a
Christina let's here let's add a Kevin
let's see Poli there might be a few
multiple multiples so they're all here
we have four times in a row but it's
fine he likes to give high fives we'll
just leave that so they're all kind of
on top of each other I'm actually going
to change them because it looks looks a
little crowded they're all on top of
each other we want to arrange them on
the screen here so we're going to use
some CSS grid fun have you all used CSS
grid for how many of you used it I'm
seeing like a quarter of you it's really
amazing like oh it just gives me the
shivers I love CSS grid okay so we have
our click area right and the first thing
that we want to do is give it a display
of grid I'm first going to style the
list items so that you can see it and
see what's happening here I'm going to
give it a background of Dodger blue
unlike the papaya whip that Glen's like
I am a Dodger blue kind of girl so we
have that color I'm going to then go
back into our grid and applies the magic
nothing is happening yet but when I give
it a grid template it's just
automatically going to fall into place
I want that 3x3 grid so I'm going to
just use the fractional unit which says
cake up as much of this remaining space
as possible within this fractional unit
so if I use one it's going to all be
even to each other and then I can say I
want one two three rows and then I want
one two three columns you can also use a
repeat property inside of grid to do
this but it's a little bit more clear
right now if I just do when fr one Fr
went too far
okay so this isn't moving but I'm
wondering what I wrote wrong when I fire
over one well let's let's find out as I
save this out the the board isn't giving
me a background here either let's see if
I I spell something wrong what is it
click area you're right it's game area
that's exactly this is why I love you
all you're sitting in front of me
awesome so if I give it the correct
class name you know live coding who
thought something could go wrong
it appears powerfully as I expected and
then here I can give it a grid gap of
say like 20 pixels and only the space
between the pixels moves it's like magic
nothing on the outside we don't have to
work with these like weird end values or
last child hacks it just works the way
you expect it to and now we're going to
do that mysterious second biggest
problem of computer science and Center
things so we're going to vertically
align this with display flex we're going
to do a line items Center and we're
going to do justify content center here
so once I save that all these elements
will be kind of aligned within the space
we're going to then use some margins
here to center this area we're going to
give it a width of like a tvw and a
height of say a tvw and then we want to
do a margin so you're Auto so it's
centered inner screen and looks a little
bit nicer here cool we've got that now
we have this shield so I just pre wrote
it because it's just placement
background with height absolute
positioning but we have it in front of
our character so when you click you
can't access that hand unless you go a
little higher to get that score value up
we want to bring the score back into
here so let's go ahead and add that back
in and when I click up you'll see that I
can reach the hand here but not here so
we'll needs to go back in to our board
or our game play file to make this even
harder because we can still tally up
these points it's
not something of challenging until we
make it challenging and we can do that
by using some animations so let's go
back into this file and add some CSS
animations we can use keyframes to do
this we're going to say keyframes of
move because we don't have to be
creative we'll just really quickly come
up with a name I'm going to have this go
from 0% to 50% because at 60% I'm going
to have it alternate and it's just going
to go like a little bounce so we're
going from 0 to 100 and I'm going to use
a transform property to move this in a
way that it's going to translate why to
move up and down so I'm going to say
it's transform translate Y and it's
going to go from negative 25 pixels to
25 pixels I'm going to apply this to
both the character and the click area
this animation which is a move I'm going
to say is 0.5 seconds it's going to be
forever they're going to be jumping up
at us infinite and it's going to be
alternating for that bounce and it's
going to be moving forward because we
want the paint to move forward all right
going to save that and now our
characters are all jumping up at the
same rate ready to give us high-five it
is much harder now to click and to grab
them while they're up there but it's
still kind of weird that our characters
are all moving at the same rate here on
the screen so we can now use another for
loop in sass but instead of doing it
inside of our class we're going to
generate our classes within the for loop
so let's say at 4 we'll use i from 1
through 9 which is the number of
characters that we have you can also use
a variable for this we'll set a speed
and here we can use a sass random
function within this to create different
animation durations different speeds for
our characters so let's use random and
we'll do random times like 1.5 and then
we have to add the second so that it
knows what we're using here for the
duration so now we can say we want our
list items and we can use end child a
selector we're going to interpolate that
I variable so we can use it within this
class name this class like that we're
creating here and inside of that we want
to give it the speed so here we're going
to say for all the characters and all of
the click area
within this list item with an end of 1
through 9 we are going to change up the
animation duration and overwrite it to
be again interpolating that speed
variable hit save and now they will all
be moving at different rates hope we got
an excited Tim and Kevin here mmm maybe
I like this 2.5 alright that's a little
bit better Tim is still very excited to
be playing this game so this is starting
to look more like what we're expecting
but we still are going to ultimately
always be winning because we don't have
a time limit yet so let's add a time
limit we go back into our index we can
then create a class like a stopper class
so we'll create a stopper and inside
this will have like an h3 that says game
over sorry and we'll save that and then
we can go into our board I have it here
again so I could just uncomment that
it's currently just on our page but what
this is doing is its styling it so that
is being an override of the page it's
taking the full width and height getting
that background of cyan I'm increasing
the font size a little bit for styling
purposes but now we want to move this
off of the page so we want to do H
transform translate Y of negative 100 Z
H so it just moves off the page and we
want that to eventually appear in when
we want thing to move in CSS we have to
add an animation so let's add that let's
do a keyframe for stopper we'll name the
animation stopper and we'll do a from
init to here and we can use this value
this transform translate why so we
wanted to move from negative 100 V H to
0 V H so it goes back to the original
location on the page there's kind of
like that reverse animation that we
heard about before with some of those
awesome data visualizations so we're
going to apply this to our stopper we're
going to say we want to add an animation
of stopper make that 0.5 seconds this
could also be a variable really great
for you're creating style systems to
variable eyes your animations they have
the same look and feel to them also with
your Bezier curves and any kind of
animation curve you have there I'm just
using linear for now so I'm leaving it
at its default and so I have this
animation I also
on the paint to go forward so it ends as
it goes so I save this is pops in but
that's a very short game the game is
like less than half of a second long so
they can use this animation delay
property to make our game
eight seconds longer or something like
that so once i refresh this page it's
going to take eight seconds and tell the
animation stops working and I want to
pull this out into a game link variable
so we're going to have a game length be
eight seconds and then I can diffuse
that and use that and propagate it
through the rest so if you have noticed
we've lost our score the score is now
behind our stopper because we haven't
styled it yet an entire score is an h2
don't fight me on this it's just a demo
yes you should namespace all of these
things but we then want to style at h2
that appears above we're just going to
do a z-index here of ten we are going to
give it a position:relative and then
we're going to also give this an
animation we want this to appear but not
from negative 100 to zero we want this
to appear from zero to negative fifty VH
because that way it can pop in and kind
of go in with this game over
so I haven't applied this yet oh gosh
this is at the top of the page I think
just title this has to be positioned oh
that's why okay so this this needs to be
scored we haven't applied this yet we're
going to apply it here when we apply
this animation you're my favorite person
in here right now thank you
so here we go we're going to apply the
stopper we're going to have it have the
same animations laid but maybe we want
to add like 0.25 seconds so it occurs a
little bit later than the last one and
so once we play this refresh after eight
seconds the first one will appear after
eight point two five seconds the second
one will appear and we'll have a nice
little pop in effect for this game so
that appears that way I want this to
continue to look a little nicer so we
can do some more things here by applying
some um
some notifications you've clicked on the
characters like right now if I'm playing
this game I clicking on the characters
they're still moving around you don't
really get any feedback the UI of this
isn't that great because I don't know
that I've really gotten the score and
left I look down so we can then go into
our click area and say if the click area
is checked we want to stop the animation
and this is why before when I was
applying those animations I applied them
to both the click area and the character
instead of doing the character wrapper
because we're using this click area and
it's sibling the div right next to it to
apply the stopping so with this check we
want to say animation nun we also want
to say pointer events nun because that
means that it's no longer going to be
able to be clicked on you can't unclick
you can't remove your score
we also are say any character next to
this is going to get an animation nun
and we want to maybe add a filter so
here we can apply like a grayscale
filter to it and as we play we can
refresh once I have clicked on this
eager little person they're hard to
click sometimes they they should be
stopping so let's debug click area
checks animation done pointer events
none let's see this theoretically should
be stopping but I'm wondering why it's
not maybe I'm not clicking on them maybe
I am when this happens you have all
these things being saved so believe me
this usually works I'm going to go to
another branch I have which is called
step 12 and then I'm going to hit gulp
and it's going to all be magically done
for me when i refresh I'm going to click
that and it's stopping now
so it looks like the code is the same I
may have done some kind of strange thing
I'm going to refresh that I'm going to
just close out of it and open board as
CSS but yeah maybe I just wrote this
wrong anyway as I'm clicking this it's
stopping the propagation of the event
this character stops moving we now know
that we clicked them as they stopped
moving that one which is really hard to
click we have a
SCOR we have our game let's add that
heart back and then we created since
that heart is an after pseudo element we
can go and then just extend the class
we've created so we can say add extend
dot pixelized heart and when we replay
the game a little heart animation a
little heart will appear once I've
clicked it so I clicked it the heart is
there we can even give this a margin top
of negative 25 pixels so it appears just
on top of that character and we have
created here in like 35 minutes a CSS
game live on stage with all of your help
so thank you it's a difficult game
[Applause]
[Music]
so what I really want you to get from
the talk is while you do these things
there are so many a CSS properties that
you might not use for everything but
there are so many uses of them that are
creative uses if you go onto code pen
you can find through really awesome
examples of CSS games you can even play
this game if you go to this site you
know IM slash CSS comp EU 2017 post your
high score let's see how you do you can
also fork this from code pen and make
your own game you can improve it you can
build upon it you can play it and you
can make it even better with some of
those awesome things that we've learned
today thank you so much for having me
and thanks for making the web fun and
beautiful okay
[Applause]